Now I can draw the decision boundary, this time in scikit-learn, and voila.
This is what it looks like.
So, you can see immediately, where before in Naive Bayes,
we had something that was a little bit, little bit curvy maybe.
Our SVM decision boundary is now perfectly straight.
And of course, this is the line that's going to give us the maximum margin
between the decision boundary and any misclassified points, so
the points on either side.
So, just to make that a little bit more illustrated on this particular example,
that's, that means that it's going to have,
it's going to maximize all of these distances here.
The points that are nearby the decision boundary, it's going to try and
find a decision boundary where all of these little orange lines are as big as
we can make them.
That means that there's as much separation between the two classes as possible.